das ärgert mich wirklich dass armin
laschet dieser vorwurf gemacht wird dass
ihr diese rote socken kampagne macht
also dass er wohlauf scholz hier drängt
und zwingen sie zu sagen dass das nicht
mit der gts so damit der linkspartei
macht darüber reden sich viele auf das
ist ein alter wahlkampf server was soll
was soll arminia steht auch machen l
nicht zehn prozent oder sogar mehr
hinter dem schlechtesten ergebnis dass
die union sei nach kriegsende in
umfragen erzielt hat bei der letzten
bundestagswahl erzielt hat ehrlich - 10
darunter muss irgendetwas tun um seine
wahl ja anhängerschaft zu mobilisieren
um tatsächlich auch die kernwählerschaft
erreichen die rote socken kampagne hat
funktioniert 1994 da war helmut kohl vor
vorgänger von angela merkel in
bedrängnis
er zog die rote socken kampagne raus
sein generalsekretär hintze peter hintze
das machen und gewann dann schließlich
wieder die mehrheit gegen die spd den
damaligen kanzlerkandidaten rudolf
scharping also es hat einmal
funktioniert und hier geht es darum die
kernwählerschaft zu mobilisieren die
vielleicht immer noch zum teil denkt der
verein steht im osten und bald kommt der
wandel ist irgendeine möglichkeit gibt
dass sich die spd mit dieser links
partei verbündet
das ist eine sehr spannende these und
ich habe heute schon die reaktion
michael tschek nicht nur deine meinung
sondern ich habe heute mal gecheckt was
die anderen so dazu sagen zu der
kampagne und viele aus der spd am heute
schon getwittert oder gepostet sie
würden jetzt schon den einfluss merkels
vermissen weil unter ihr wäre das nicht
passiert
das ist spannend was immer das heißt
also das ist ja auch relativ
wohlfeil diese geschichte war angela
merkel von vier koalition eine mit der
fdp eingegangen ist um drei mit der spd
also große koalition das heißt sie
musste das gar nicht befürchten dass das
passiert und
wahrscheinlich wäre mit ihr dann
tatsächlich eine neuauflage der großen
koalition oder in welcher form auch
immer wieder das wahrscheinlichste
gewesen und insofern kann man sagen dass
sie sich da raushält aber sie hat ja
gestern eben in anderer form gemacht
aber ich sehe nicht dass sie sich da
unbedingt jetzt diesmal anders
einbringen würde wenn sie noch kanzlerin
wäre ja ich glaube olaf scholz ich
glaube armin laschet hat
recht dass er diesen punkt macht der ist
wirklich berechtigt die spd müsste das
klären das wäre wirklich nicht gut wenn
die linkspartei verantwortung bekommt
nicht wegen ihrer sed-vergangenheit die
sind ja alle schon längst weg aus
dietmar bartsch stellen moskau noch
probiert hat aber praktischerweise ja
für ein nato mitgliedschaft ist ja genau
aber also das wäre wirklich nicht gut
die haben auch zu jedem eu-erweiterung
schritt zu jedem eu vertrag haben die
man einen gesagt und erzählen das ist
alles eine neoliberale verschwörung
assistpunkt ist richtig aber ich glaube
er ist politisch unklug warum war jetzt
gewöhnen sich die deutschen noch gerade
daran mensch der olaf schulz könnte
wirklich kanzler werden sie alle
überrascht dass er vorne liegt und das
jetzt weiter zu thematisieren die
deutschen an diesen gedanken zu gewöhnen
das ist nicht klug er sollte lieber
eigene themen voranstellen er hat doch
ein klima paket frische klimakonzept
vorschlag mit jungen leuten also wir
können klimaschutz besser hat man nichts
von gehört weil sie alle rote sorgen
reden er hat auf dem wirtschaftstag
gesagt friedrich merz mit meinen
wirtschaftsminister er könnte was zur
inneren sicherheit sagen also er müsste
versuchen eigenes hochzuziehen sie haben
auch wegzukommen von diesem tatsächlich
haben sie recht ungerechten image das er
im netz hat und ich glaube in dem man
ein schlaglicht auf olaf scholz leuchtet
gewöhnen sich die leute daran dass der
kanzler fertigte können das ganz
spannend ist was robin alexander sagt
dass begegnet mir dem wahlkampf von
armin laschet ganz häufig diese
thematisierung von themen die eigentlich
keine gewinner themen sind für ihn etwas
ganz anderes aber es gibt diese szene wo
er so komisch in seinen ice beißt und
sich im netz darüber lustig gemacht
haben er hat dann ein erklärvideos
hinterhergeschoben seine kampagnen
leitung und erklärt warum es für ihn
normal ist mal ein eis zu essen und
hinterher und das ist ein ganz normaler
bürger sinn ist von ihm es gibt dieses
furchtbare foto wo er bei in der
hochwasser in der flut da irgendwo steht
mit dem bürger sich unterhält der bürger
steht im regen ist platzt auf ihn runter
armin laschet wird beschirmt von einem
sicherheitsbeamten
furchtbar dann hat tatsächlich auch
wieder die kampagne begonnen mit dem
journalisten verband korrektiv dieses
foto zu interpretieren und hinter jetzt
geschrieben warum das alles ungerecht
ist was
verbreitet wenn in der außenpolitik gibt
es einen diplomaten spruch wenn justine
hole full of stock picking also hör auf
zu graben wenn du im auf diesen kreisen
nennt man das eine schwarze katze ja ich
habe wenn gar nichts mehr geht
wenn man keine themen hat wenn man keine
themen hat die wirklich völlig fehlen ja
bisher im wahlkampf dann macht man ein
anti wahlkampf dann geht man hat man aus
anderen parteien ja auch schon mal
erlebt so in den 90ern beispielsweise
also wird uns damit dies nicht werden
innerlich an den 98er wahlkampf auch
noch also das gibt's natürlich
ich sehe ist wie du wann tut armee das
schiff ist ein recht dann wenn man sich
in das parteiprogramm der linkspartei
wirklich ein ließ dann muss man sagen
die partei will aus deutschland eine
sozialistische planwirtschaft machen und
das ist natürlich in diesem in diesem
wahlkampf rote socken man macht ihn gut
finden oder schlecht finden aber das
kernthema was adressiert wird ist
achtung schaut einmal was diese partei
eigentlich will und es gibt einen
kanzlerkandidaten wir sprachen vor ein
paar minuten schon drüber der es sich
offen hält und er sich weiterhin offen
hält auch wenn man sagt ja mit der nato
und das ist also der sich weiterhin
offen hält mit einer partei zu koalieren
die die banken verstaatlichen will die
enteignungen will die raus aus der nato
will und es gibt viele weitere die die
auch zb der bildungssektor komplett
wieder verstaatlichen will dass es dann
bildung aller staat keine privatschule
mehr also da ist dann im zweifel auch
volks erziehung mit so einer partei will
olaf scholz hat kollegen das ist glaube
ich schon in ordnung dass das einmal
massiv vonseiten beispielsweise der
union an die liste
mit den auch umleitungen bei den museen
im gesicht ein gewehrt und das richtig
dass das armenische das anspricht weil
wir müssen ja in diesem wahlkampf
endlich mal da hin kommt dass wir auch
auf die großen unterschiede anspricht
weil es ist ein riesengroßer unterschied
ob rot rot grün regieren wird oder ob
das irgend eine andere konstellation ist
und ich hab's ja eben schon mal gesagt
für mich ist eine brandmauer in richtung
nicht nur der afg sondern auch der
linken weil dann geht es ja nicht nur um
lade um außenpolitik da geht auch nicht
nur um im bankensektor da geht es
insgesamt um das system wie stellen wir
uns gesellschaft vor und linke ich sage
immer so krass das ist für mich keine
soziale politik die die machen das ist
eine asoziale politik also wenn ich ein
menschenbild habe wo ich einen menschen
sehe der entweder so schutzbedürftig ist
dass ich komplett auf ihn aufpassen muss
das ist ihr gehirn bewegen kann und
überhaupt nicht mehr kreativ und und und
und leistungsstark sein kann wenn er
wenn ihr ihn als so hinterhältig aber
zeigen dass ich eben regelt oder
schütten muss und wir sprechen hier auch
nochmal über ein thema wo ich ständig
misstrauen habe wo ich die bürger gehen
muss damit sie bloß nichts anstellen
dann ist das ein zutiefst negatives
menschenbild ein ganz ganz negatives
sicht auf die dinge sich schrecklich
also wenn sowas in regierungshandeln
kommt dann wird unsere gesellschaft auch
eine andere sein da werden wir nicht
mehr dieses positive menschen mit haben
schauen wir doch mal ja olaf scholz will
doch gar nicht mit denen ihr
sagen aber dass man kann es sein dass er
das nicht mehr ich kenne und schätze aus
hamburg ich weiß ja wieder drauf ist
aber dann soll er es auch sagen und vor
allen dingen geht es mir darum dass wir
im wahlkampf endlich mal die
entscheidenden themen adressieren und
was ich bin da schon sagen würde wenn du
das schon mal mit der roten socken
kampagne dann geht auch den nächsten
schritt und dann adressieren auch die
grundsätzliche unterschiede macht das
auch mal deutlich war das wäre ja ein
aufhänger um das mal deutlich zu machen
dann würde sinn machen nur
geht dann leider also zum besten jahr so
das was sie gerade sagt mit rw das ja
gar nicht dann soll das besonders sagen
dieser wahlkampf ist ja ein schummel und
mogel wahlkampf einmal ganz ernst sind
hier wird ganz ganz viel versprochen von
allen parteien aber es wird nie gesagt
wer es am ende einig bezahlen oder was
die kosten sind geht für nahezu alle
parteiprogramme und das ist ja auch
genau dass man redet den wähler so ein
bisschen schön weich und cremig und
seifig am ende kommt eine rechnung die
muss bezahlt werden und die wird aber
bisher im wahlkampf auch komplett
verschwiegen meint credo wer immer zu
sagen haben und seien wir doch ehrlich
der wähler ist ja nicht ganz blöd und er
hat auch das recht aufgeklärt zu werden
also er soll aufgeklärt werden mit dem
olaf scholz koalieren wird oder nicht
und er soll aufgeklärt werden über die
kosten der wahlprogramme ich finde es
ehrlich gesagt unfassbar dass es
überhaupt so normal ist dass jemand es
offen lässt also müssen sich jetzt mal
überlegen einem lächeln würde sagen auch
ja aber ich mit der afg zusammen gehe
oder nicht das weise das so das wäre
total aufschreiben ich frag mich wann
die linke partei ist geschafft hat so
salonfähig zu werden dass wir das ganz
normal debattieren das lässt mich ja
gegen einen link sprechen so viele
argumente dass man den af.de vergleich
wirklich nicht braucht man kann ganz
ruhig auf diese wahlprogramm gucken und
auf das was die neulich zur bundeswehr
abgestimmt haben und was die vorhaben
und das reich dass man die nicht wählen
will dann braucht man die nicht mit der
afg gleichzusetzen und warum will olaf
scholz das nicht doch nicht weil er sich
nur gezeigt was ist gerade getan habe
ich habe es getan weil es für mich beide
extreme parteien sind sind für mich
beides keine demokratischen parteien
deswegen vergleiche gut bin kann man
natürlich nicht vergleichen
olaf scholz wird eine knappe mehrheit
haben vielleicht acht stimmen zu 48
stimmen wird er immer brauchen in den
nächsten linksfraktion sitzen aber
mindestens 15 irre und das weiß scholz
und wer mit den koaliert der kommt nicht
weit und das will ja nicht was er will
ist die linke in der hand zu haben um
frau suding und ihre freunde von der fdp
zu erpressen weil olaf scholz braucht
eine jemand aus dem bürgerlichen lager
sie und ihre freunde die müssen über
eine brücke gehen und diese brücke wird
gezimmert wenn ihr kommt müssen wir
nicht mit den linken und noch ein paar
andere aber das geht nicht so und jetzt
kann man durchaus sagen das ist
verwerflich und ich habe ja auch gesagt
laschets punkt ist innerlich richtig ich
halte ihn aber nach wie vor für taktisch
im wahlkampf unklug und erst gibt den
zweiten punkt warum olaf scholz sich das
offen hält das sind saskia esken und
kevin kühnert ganz klar die würden
natürlich ihm seien bisher wirklich muss
man sagen erfolgreichen wahlkampf
komplett verschließen wenn olaf scholz
eine option die frau es kann ja auch als
einig ihrer wunschkoalition genannt hat
ausschließen würde aber schon jetzt
gerade aufwenden und ich glaube je mehr
die sich äußern desto mehr geht nicht im
ferrari des olaf scholz verstehens
geraten aber bevor diese rot-rot-grün
kampagne los gegenstand die linkspartei
bei 6 prozent tendenz fallend ihr bestes
pferd im stall sahra wagenknecht hat ein
parteiausschlussverfahren
man kennt die namen der
parteivorsitzende nicht wenn sie ins
fernsehen kommen blamieren sie sich also
es lief doch nicht gut für die
linkspartei und diese rot-rot-grünes
geführt nutzt den weil die plötzlich
wieder wahrgenommen werden
[Musik]